I don't really know how to explain this
but Donald Trump appears not to know or
to be lying about where his father was
born which is a really weird thing I
mean I'm sort of struggling for the
language to apply here when Donald Trump
said that nambia was a country could
have been a verbal slip he probably just
doesn't have a firm grasp on African
countries and geography and that would
sort of be expected a lot of people
don't have a firm grasp on African
geography when Donald Trump said he's
done more than any president ever for
Puerto Rico he might not know that he's
been a disaster on Puerto Rico it might
be a political calculation in some way
maybe he forgot that he actually hasn't
been that great for Puerto Rico but
Donald Trump has claimed again that his
father was born in Germany and his
father wasn't born in Germany Donald
Trump's grandfather was born in Germany
and this is raising more questions about
cognitive decline I don't bring this up
to make fun of people cognitive decline
is not funny but if the president is
suffering from cognitive decline or pre
dementia we need to know that that
that's a major problem and Donald Trump
could could sort of be dissociating here
he's moving information around in his
mind as people in various stages of
cognitive decline sometimes do it's his
grandfather who's actually German but he
says that it was his father check out
this video from the Oval Office and if
you notice if you're watching this thing
happens that's common in people who
start to struggle cognitively but are
still in the early stages he starts to
say his dad was born in Germany but if
you're looking at the reaction on his
face he seems to sort of recognize that
something he's saying isn't quite right
it's almost like internal Trump is
recognizing that external Trump is doing
something a little bit weird and it's
not clear whether his mind can totally
parse it I mean this is sad
take a look at this I mean Germany
honestly is not paying their fair share
I've great respect for Angela and I have
great respect for the country my father
is German right was German
and born in a a very wonderful place in
Germany and so I have a great feeling
for Germany but they're not paying what
they should be paying yeah so Trump's
dad Fred Trump was born in New York I
mean he wasn't born in Germany Trump's
grandfather Friedrich Trump was born in
Germany came to the United States in
1885 this is not good and it actually
gets even worse Pat pointed out to me
that there's another moment during this
exact same press conference press
availability I guess you would call it
where Donald Trump twice says the word
oranges like the citrus fruit instead of
origins like the source of something and
again both times he seems unsure of what
he's saying something seems to glitch in
his head where he realizes he's saying
something wrong but it's almost like
beyond him to even control it take a
look and I hope that this investigation
now which is finished
it's totally finished no collusion no
obstruction I hope they now go and take
a look at the oranges or the oranges of
the investigation the beginnings of that
investigation you look at the origin of
the investigation where it started how
it started who started it whether its
McCabe or Comey or a lot of them where
does it go how high up in the White
House did it go you will all get
Pulitzer Prizes okay you're gonna all
get Pulitzer Prizes you should have
looked at it a long time ago and that's
the only thing that's disappointing to
me about the Muller report the Muller
report
I wish covered the oranges how it
started yeah what do you make of that
Pat I mean you can tell that this is
he's not so far gone that he doesn't
recognize he's having trouble saying
what he thinks he should be saying
there's definitely some recognition
there but it's a very strange behavior
he can definitely tell that he's saying
it wrong it's surprising to me that he
wouldn't just stick with a substitute
like pick a different word beginnings
what have you and just continue using
the word beginnings why does he have to
keep go
back in trying to pronounce origins
correctly just give up on it that would
be my take I was thinking of this story
from when I was a kid as many of you
know I was born in Argentina my dad was
born in Argentina his dad was born in
Argentina and in Spanish there are two
words to say here there's the word aqui
and there's the word acha now in
argentina in most situations
acha is more common but it kind of
depends on the particulars of the
circumstances and that's the one I was
basically familiarized with when I was
six years old
um and when I moved to the United States
most of the Spanish speakers that I was
around in elementary school at
kindergarten and first grade were from
Puerto Rico and in Puerto Rico it's much
more common to say aqui in fact I would
exclusively only hear them say aqui so
in my mind I associated aqui with people
born in Puerto Rico and akka with people
born in Argentina so once when I was
like six I remember my dad said aqui and
for some reason I looked at him and I
said dad what were you born in Puerto
Rico with total sincerity and
seriousness and he said David no I I was
born in Argentina you know that my
father was born in Argentina I was born
in Argentina you were born in Argentina
and I said oh yeah that's right and so
what when I see Trump do this and say
his dad was born in Germany when he
wasn't short of being a little kid or
suffering from some actual cognitive
decline I don't understand how one can
miss state where their parent is from
unless they don't know them at all and
Trump did know his dad my mom is from
Argentina
her dad is from Poland that's not
something I would forget if at some
point I say my mom was born in Poland
and went to Argentina
something would be very wrong with me I
mean it would be I I can only imagine it
would be a medical condition of some
kind and people are saying online it's a
very dumb thing for Trump to lie about
the birthplace of his father I don't
think he's lying I think something is
wrong here and we've interviewed mental
health professionals who believe
something is very very wrong here and I
want to hear from you what do you think
is going
on here you can let us know on our
Instagram page david pakman show you can
find us on Instagram follow me while
you're there at David Pakman part two of
my interview with 20/20 Democratic
presidential candidate Andrew yang comes
up right after this short break
today's program was made possible in
part by simple habit an app for iOS
Android and web browser that gives you
access to more than 2,000 guided
meditations you can try it free for one
week by going to simple habit comm slash
Pakman simple habit has meditations made
specifically for anxiety falling asleep
overcoming procrastination getting
focused there's a meditation for almost
anything you are dealing with in life
and there is constantly new scientific
research emerging about the benefits of
meditating regarding your physical
health your mental well-being your
social life your cognitive performance
it's a long list
I personally make meditation part of my
day I've been doing it for a while and
simple habit makes it incredibly easy to
stick to a meditation routine each
guided meditation is just five minutes
long they have meditations specifically
designed for waking up for your daily
commute when you get home from work
every part of your day the massive
variety of different kinds of
meditations that simple habit offers is
what really sets the app apart and they
just won the 2018 Google Play award for
best well-being app you can try it
completely free for a week by going to
simple habit calm slash Pakman I think
you'll love it I've put a link right
underneath this video